the youtubers is Charlie think everyone
its many questions for this week's korra
Q&A
everyone had turned the questions about
the giant mech what team course gonna do
kinda shit is gonna go down the finale
so let's get to it
also real quick heads up if you guys
would be interested in me doing live
cuny's on my twitch channel just let me
know I'm totally into doing that
un Sueno them I work at the end to this
ever was pushing the absurd if you
haven't seen it yet but
starting with question for once knew a
man ass now the question is
why a giant mech NY only one when have a
leadership's plants or even tanks you
make business they like have like a
giant
army yet I think the reason is because
they wanted to do something different
visually
from a perspective Mike and Brian and
could be wrote want to do something that
would just
terrify people it mostly made me think
Evangelion Baloch people pointed to
Iron Giant there's a whole lotta make
enemy the point to
Mike Brown like the reference love their
favor animate like to legally so
it is a big enemy theories out there
that you really enjoy
I'm sure that there's something in
Legend of Korra it is a reference to
that
usually it's really minor things though
but the other thing about the giant mech
is the Eagle Point to the drill at
bossing say to the giant super weapon
so I think it's less about the giant
itself in more about the idea the super
weapon
there's a lot of the more technical
people i've seen. commenting on how the
recall will from the laser would rip the
arm of the giant
I tried to over analyze that too much
then is the issue the reload time
there's a lot of the questions that
haven't been answered about it that I
think that the address an episode 12 20
in court raised take it on
so short answer giant make because they
wanted you to crack your pants
Liberty dance sequences like that so
wouldn't be surprising and you would be
able to do that awesome godzilla reveal
socday just wanna go out on a cool
ending day and the logic
question number two we asked is a chorus
Pierre bender
can she been the spirit weapon thing or
something
so it possible that she could absorb the
energy from that blast
as far as we know she only redirected or
dodge it whenever she was fighting in
about 2 she was acting more like a tank
just soaking the damage
we haven't seen her do a Utah thing
where she absorbs the energy and
dissipated
but I'm really hoping is the solution to
the laser is going to be
something much more personal to use but
our junior to sabotage it
he helped build it so he should know how
to take it down they just as much more
personal to me
him turning against the person that he
loves and I do think he still loves
Scooby ra
even though she totally just try to take
them out there were a whole lotta
questions about what's going on in Psych
appears head so
ideas and theories question number three
Kristen as
what you think going to become a bit our
junior Inc appears relationship but
everything said and done
so I actually feel something really
tragic coming on I don't think the
Cougars gonna die I don't think was
gonna killer
if she does diet but not gonna be
because court pressure their school or
anything
it seems that they both love each other
and he's going to love her behind bars
I think the real question is Is what
needs to happen before the characters
can forgive each other for what's
happened
career seems pretty irredeemable at this
point so either she goes to jail
she dies either way I don't either but
are juniors gonna stop loving her
if you member he suggested that they go
home to they could be together
I think he's going to try and find a way
to sell her on running away so they can
be together
off by themselves wondering around there
been a lot to be cared that goes I for
instance
he's became a nomad and walked around
for the rest of his life who've Europe
could do the same thing with
but our junior at this point he does not
care about Republic City
or the earth Empire or anything he just
cares about who you're a who fears the
one
it's got her had messed up that's really
the only big complaint that I have about
this season so far as because it's so
condense
we don't have time to get the side
episodes that explain why kubera
is so hardcore which number four team be
the ass
how long you think the computer has been
building that giant mech suit
they couldn't have built it before they
discovered speared by a weapon yeah
actually I do I think they'd
started building at the minute they took
southville I don't think the mech
was built because this beard fine weapon
I think that the met was built to be a
Mac
in that they just attacked his beard
fine weapon to it after the fact
which number five purple conscience ask
do you think that will seize you go get
in the battle
maybe even izumi yeah like people asking
about the Fire Nation wTF is the Fire
Nation
yes I do think that they'll show up at
the end but I don't think they're gonna
get involved in the conflict I think the
conflict is pretty much over
there will still be a battle like this
up to take down the Mac and they had to
deal with two beers army
but it's not going to be the big war
there was going to be before president
break a surrender
on door then I gonna pull the rug right
out from under us and do an Action List
finale mister gonna be a lot of fighting
but if you're asking about to go
fighting like he find and book 3
no I don't either that's going to happen
I just think he'll show up at the end
it will get that final moment we're all
the world leaders meet in Republic City
question number six david is a US what
do you think about prince will he's been
doing
oddly good lately yes I think they just
might
to show that he can totally lead the
Earth Kingdom like he has a brain inside
his head
even though he's kinda dumb is something
a very character
someone who has intelligence but it's
not plainly evident just from talking to
them
but he knows how to deal with people
like he's a people person he doesn't do
really well but technical details
that's why I think that when the deal
with kubera he's going to be installed
as the Earth Kingdom leader and he'll be
a much better King
then the earth Queen was much more
democratic and yes I do think Michael
will become one of his advisers
ever will be bummed is the team
correspond up but remembered the world
is small they can travel around pretty
fast
question number seven avatar song as do
you think the but our baruch will turn
the spirit can
into another spare bomb to saying like
will they sabotage it blowed up
I think yet I think the take down the
Mac and I'll take out the weapon
and it seems confusing about why but our
might help them but I think that they'll
be
a deal like I have something is headed
where he thinks if I helped them
take down this giant weapon and disable
it then they'll let me leave with Cu
vera and we can be together
as for victims said that a couple the
hummingbird survived so I think the
whole palette wanna going close
julie is probably the one that would
palette in that situation in very quick
just go in and try to take out the
weapon
platypus to bear to the rescue question
for eight
a meal ask do you think that will ever
find out by two beers so intent on
uniting the earth Empire
will cast member die in the last
episodes no I'm not expecting anyone the
diana the Coro careers gonna die i mean
it is
is possible I meet the final episode
cora coram
might sacrifice herself I hope that she
doesn't and I think
I said a couple times but I don't think
they're gonna completely explain why
cool beer so
crazy about uniting the earth Empire I
think she just wants the land
because people want me and it like
Israel thank you take a piece of land in
say
this is Bert everyone now but it
actually belong to another group of
people before that
so because be conflict in real life just
like it is with Israel and Palestine
I think the character would have come up
a little bit better if they had shown
her as a liberator
but at this point I think they just want
her to be the clear villain
I'm not feeling super sympathetic about
her so maybe something is going to
happen in the next two episodes that
will make her a little bit more
sympathetic
like maybe something happened to her and
her childhood that we don't know about
yet
maybe something happened to enter
travels I think it would be a big
disservice
to not mention any those things but it's
kinda question I think they were totally
answer
a comic on so if you get a chance to ask
some questions the comic-con
think it really eliminates stuff like
that if they don't do it on the
commentary
that as you know the place to sup look
forward to the DVD commentary
question for nine safire starr ass do I
think the Chimera
would feel hatred for the Fire Nation
because what happened during a hundred
year war
go after them because that so I think
could be rude pry find any reason that
she could pick up to take their land
regardless aware her head space was like
what she was thinking her logic before
I think now she just gonna invent
whatever reason she needs to to
accomplish our goal
to rationalize it in her head like
killing but our I think she saw the
corner was going to use him
against her so she wanted to take that
advantage away
it's not quite as clear that was with
see here not institutionalize the evil
the year was a fanatic about his ideas
amis de lys he's creepy in that way
is so calm he doesn't seem crazy at all
he is a little intense
we haven't really seen viewers
motivation so that's a bit of a weakness
the series in general but yeah I think
you just invent whatever reason she
needed to go out to the other nations
question for 10 Rens do you think the
cougar is going to go on mental like a
dealer in the end
who that would be fun I don't think it's
going to be exactly like that but I do
think that she's gonna break down
I think we are kinda expect court to end
so that means clear has to lose
she seems really cold but she doesn't
seem like she has been together quite as
much as a year did
I think it anything is going to make her
breakdown it'll be but our junior
I think the to them I think Ill be
something really personal this is what
I'm hoping
I think that would be the best way to go
out but you had a montar lock
you had the two brothers together they
went out that way I would like to see
something similar with could be wrong
but our
hopefully they won't commit suicide I
don't wanna see that if she is Hitler
I don't wanna see her commit suicide
like Hitler did
in real life killer neighbor on I guess
that makes but our junior Eva Braun in
that situation
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions as always it happened to do a
lot people asking me about doing Last
Airbender videos
yes I will be doing those allow me to
explain so what's gonna happen is
is next week we'll get the two-part
finale I do a couple extra videos for
that
to specific to the finale and then I'll
try and start posting
avatar last airbender videos within a
couple days that
I don't know how frequently that's going
to happen whenever TV comes back in the
spring
I'm have a much harder time my video
schedules gonna be a lot more fall so
it'll be a little bit harder so might be
one a week
but we can figure that out as we go
along also to about the light which
Q&A's
so I'll is the answer questions whenever
I'm streaming games on Twitch
but I can actually use that I can use
the twitch channel to just answer
questions first up it doesn't have to be
for video games
so if you really wanna see me do live
cuny's first up
just let me know in the comments below
but which channel is just twitch slash
emergency %ah sinners link in the
description I liked which a little
better than I like Google+
does the technology is a little bit
better I only have a webcam for that
which you can see in the tub my computer
it's not quite as good as the camera
that you're seeing me on here but
if people really like it and you to
budge the organizer camera so it looks
better
from that angle congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner
learn bass Mon everybody give her a high
five you in a copy of the book 3 DVD
just be sure to message me on the back
in my channel saying get contact details
thank you in advance so do not forget
bring an extra pair pants
next week let it go right two episodes
next Friday the prices pose the most my
website
if you on your mobile phone or on a
tablet there's no extra links appear you
click onto the same as the links over
here
but the cure for my episode 11 video and
click here for all my other core videos
thank you so much for watching let's all
about I will see guys tonight